right-hander ross stripling on the mound
for the blue jays 1-3 with a 5.11 era in
eight games seven starts this season 37
innings 40 hits 11 walks and 39
strikeouts jose altuve will lead things
off against tripling jose has been very
good since birthday number 31 on may the
6th hitting 343 during that stretch as a
31 year old tuva first pitch swinging
sends one right past joe panic at third
base and the astros pick up on a
saturday where they left off friday
night swinging the bats and jose altuve
on base for the astros and now it's
carlos correa's turn the astro shortstop
boy he sought off korea panic can't make
the play and tubers gonna be out at
third what a heads up play by the blue
jays altuve trying to force the issue
took advantage of that
little weak rounder but he was thrown
out on a heads-up play one thing we know
about vladi guerrero he's got a cannon
for an arm so one out and one on for
bregman he pops it up it's playable
bow doesn't see it now simeon's behind
him and he'll make the catch bushet
never saw it off the bat and so simeon
picked up the slack two out and now it's
jordan alvarez to the plate the astros
d8 change have right at the bottom of
the knees for strike three alvarez
called out on strikes or kitty on the
mound facing the toronto blue jays for
the second time this season he faced
them earlier in may back on may 7th
marcus simeon leading off marcus simon
goes down and strokes wood into right
field so the leadoff man on for beau
bechet the blue jays shortstop swing and
a miss good morning good afternoon and
good night bo buchet just blew a
fastball by him and that is out number
one so one out and one on for vladimir
guerrero junior the first baseman
breaking ball and that's popped up
on the right side playable for guriel on
the infield dirt makes the catch in fair
territory and that's out number two so
two out and simeon still at first for
right fielder tay oscar hernandez
swinging in a mess got him on a good
slider hernandez goes down and the
inning is over a couple of strikeouts
for katie works around a base hit richie
home run yesterday hitting 287 2-2
swinging a miss got him on a fastball
upstairs and jose or kitty has struck
out three of the last four hitters two
out no one on for joe panic left-handed
hitting third baseman line to right
racing back tucker looking up and it
will one hop the wall panic on his way
to second the throw in by tucker the
slide panic is out
perfect throw from tucker
the ball one hopped the wall and threw a
strike to correa getting over castro's
with three singles so far so here's
altuve with the runner on second until
he turns on that high fastball gurio's
got a strong arm while straw can run and
he's got him what a throw by korea
my oh my miles straw
was absolutely flabbergasted and he was
thrown out he didn't even slide he
thought he was going to breeze across
home plate
seventh outfield assist for guriel that
ties him for the lead in the majors and
it's a two out double for marcus semi
and he's two for two the runner in
scoring position two outs now for bull
buchet there's one to right field
sending tucker back but it's playable
and that'll do it for the blue jays in
the third a two out double by marcus
simeon one man left on base scoreless
after three here we go back-to-back knox
the astros will have first and second
here third inning where they've had
multi-hit inning here's diaz diaz with a
modest five-game hitting streak look out
oh man that's not good right around the
hand that is not good leadman's in a lot
of pain right here oh right on the back
of the hand still on the back the scary
moment when you're hitting on the hand
with so many of those little bones there
so led miss hit by a pitch on the left
hand will leave the game okay well the
bases are loaded with two outs miles
straw the batter
and now he's 3-0 on straw that's inside
bases loaded walking the astros have
their first run
a stripling walks mile straw and the
astros lead one to nothing here's
maldonado second career grand slam last
night goes after that high pitch and
strikes out so ross stripling minimizes
the damage here come the blue jays so
guerrero gets an infield hit oscar gets
a base hit to rank the blue jays have
two on this is where they do their heavy
lifting middle of the order here's
lourdes curiel jr bouncing ball through
the left side guerrero's around third
naboo jays have tied it a couple of
curiels having a chat over at first base
and here's joe panic some good at bats
descending by the jays against irkiti
second time through a little bit more
comfortable joe panic hits one high in
the air to ride get up ball get up ball
get out of here and gone
pre-run home run for joe panic
good inning for the blue jays they have
a 4-1 lead ross stripling trying to now
get through five innings so he can
qualify after the blue chase took the
lead qualify for the win
breaking bar hit the third panic to
second for one simian the first double
play and
ross stripling is through five innings
they did a nice job making a good pitch
to bregman so one on and one out for
guerrero vlady looks so comfortable at
the plate right now he swung at that
first pitch wild but the next three
pitches he slowed everything down and
he's locked in right now he's locked in
on her kitty if her kitty throws him the
pitch that he's thinking about he's
liable to hit this thing hard breaking
ball high and deep to lafia that's going
to be close it's going to stay gone
guerrero
overpowered it pat you were all over
that if he gets his pitch he's going to
hit it hard and did he ever the blue
jays have a 6-1 lead another big day for
vladi guerrero jr hernandez at second
guriel at first
two outs joe panicked to the plate a
little tapper right side and that'll be
fielded by curiel and that'll be the
final out of the inning third pitcher in
this game trent thornton the former
astro there's straw
and there's a ball and another good play
by guerrilla go ahead bladdy just do it
all today
he has had quite a day a couple of great
plays in the field some terrific base
running and of course a big day at the
plate as well lady guerrero will lead
things off for the blue jays in the
bottom of the seventh he's had quite an
afternoon vladi gets another base hit he
inside outside pitcher hits it into
right so he's had an infield single a
two run homer and a leadoff single to
right field stay hot bloody rafael dolis
will come in to try to put things away
so one out and two men on for straw
ground ball left side right at pachette
he'll throw to first and it is just in
time to get straw
guriel scores and it's six to two
toronto astros down to their final out
down by four for maldonado the high boy
in the air this should end it
reset the should stop calls for it makes
the catch and that's the ball can the
blue jays win it